So here we have gaju desk gaju mine and
gaju mining the dashboard. I'm going to
pay out the gajus that I've accumulated
by mining the gajimaru using gaju mining
software as a service. To do that I
generate a transaction to be signed
using grids. I copy this and I place it
down here in grids URL. Copy paste.
Okay.
Okay. Again in order to approve the
transaction signature request. This is
all happening onchain and not on the
website. Total security, the end of
login and passwords. But not only that,
you'll have noticed that the numbers of
gajus in my gauge desk in my account
have gone up considerably. That is
sub6cond transaction and settlement on a
proofof work blockchain. True
transformation. So I've got lots of
guards in my account sitting there in my
wallet. I already sent a small
transaction to my wife to be the very
very first which I was super excited
about and in the process probably didn't
do that good a job. And in my defense
with what I'm about to write, I was
still very excited. These are the very
first transactions to occur on the
Gajimaru.
This is the beginning of the internet of
economics. So my wife Rachel McKone has
been with me every step of the way all
the way through the the very hard yards
it took to get here and hold on to doing
things the right way for the right
reasons.
What you're also seeing here is the
capacity to send messages on the
blockchain usefully conveying business
data, personal data. You see this in
Swift today where there is a business
reason provided. So, as I say here, I
love my wife to the end of the universe
and back again because clearly it isn't
enough to get to infinity. Same thing I
tell my children. I hit okay and within
seconds you'll see this transaction has
gone through
seconds. This is done.
Now we can see the confirmation on chain
in the blockchain explorer. This is the
future here. Now.